hello welcome to my presentation on the
clinical scale production of
extracellular vesicles
in a hollow fiber bioreactor i'm john
cadwell
i'd like to take the mixner approach to
cell culture it's important i think for
you to understand that
cell culture is a relatively new
technique in the laboratory
first attempts at culturing cells in
vitro or in glass
outside of the body was by harrison in
1906
and he used frog neuronal implants on a
plasma clot
a three-dimensional cell culture matrix
subsequently we moved from glass into
plastic
now it wasn't until the late 50s that we
developed the gila cell line
we required proteolytic enzymes to make
for
single cell suspensions um
lavender flow hoods didn't come onto the
scene until the late 70s
scaling up of cell culture has always
been about more surface area
but fundamentally current
two-dimensional cell culture is
an inherently non-physiologic process we
are growing cells
sub-confluent non-porous two-dimensional
plastic dish
in the presence of fetal bovine serum
which in itself
is non-physiologic serum is plasma with
the clotting factors removed
the only time the cells will see serum
is in an activated state so
it's important to understand that cell
culture as practiced today
is inherently non-physiologic
all of these techniques to a greater
lesser degree we'll subject the cells to
what we call the feast or famine
cycle which means that glucose starts
out high
lactate starts out low there's this
period of time that the cells are
attaching to
the plastic and starting to secrete some
of their own cytokines we call
the lag phase after lag phase
glucose consumption will increase
lactate production will increase
the cells at their optimum density and
homeostatic conditions for only a short
period of time
for optimum protein production uh ev
production and cell physiology
and then just when things are getting
good it's time to trypsinize everything
we have to split the cells
the reason that we split the cells is
that nutrients come from the top down
and the bottom layer cells do not get
gas nutrients so that they die and peel
off and float away
so we must maintain the cells in a
subconfluent monolayer culture
this again is inherently non-physiologic
cell culture conditions are constantly
changing the cells spend a very small
amount of time out of the total time and
culture
in their optimum homeostatic cell
culture conditions
hollow fiber is fundamentally different
from any other way of culturing cells
and it is a three-dimensional more
viva-like way of growing cells
and it's based on the principle that
each one of these little hollow fibers
is like a filter which shaped like a
drinking straw
it's about 200 microns in diameter we
seal them in the ends
in this polycarbonate shell using a
polyurethane potting material
so that anything that goes from the ends
of the cartridges
necessarily goes to the insides of the
fiber
and typically we grow the cells on the
outside of the fiber
what we have done then is set up a
semi-permeable barrier
between where the media is flowing and
the cells are growing
it is a three-dimensional more in
vivo-like way of culturing cells
that has a profound effect on how the
cells behave in culture
this is just an illustration of what our
hollow fiber cartridge looks like
we have a loop of silicone tubing where
gas exchange takes place
we use a positive pressure displacement
pump there's a frictionless pump
frictionless pumping system so we don't
shift plastic off the pump tubing
and clog up the fibers
so a hollow fiber bioreactor a
three-dimensional capillary bioreactor
is fundamentally different from any
other way of growing cells in three
important ways
number one we have an extremely high
surface area to volume ratio
inside the cartridge just like we do in
vivo
so our standard cartridge is our c2011
cartridge
it has 4 000 square centimeters of
surface area
and a volume of 20 milliliters so we
basically have
200 square centimeters of surface area
per milliliter volume
this extremely high surface area of
volume ratio is the only way to culture
cells at
in vivo like cell densities 1 to 2 times
10 to 8 cells per mil
it is the only way to culture cells and
a density which
allows them to control and
generate their own specific micro
environment
this is super important we'll talk about
that later
cells are bound to a porous support not
a non-porous 2d flask
this means that we never have to split
the cells and passage
passage number is irrelevant nutrients
come from the bottom
up just like they do in vivo so there's
a more and fever-like way of growing
cells
again we never have to split the cells
we've cultured glioma
cell line for over two years of
continuous culture
we've produced a hybrido for over a year
of continuous culture
with no change in antibody affinity and
affinity
lastly we control the molecular cutoff
this is the measurement of the fiber
pore size and the filter size it is
measured in daltons
we have a 5 000 and a twenty thousand
dollar
molecular cut off available five kd and
twenty kd
now i think it's very important to
understand and know fundamentally
exactly what a dalton is this is one of
my pet peeves
and it will be part of the continuing
medical education questions as part of
this
seminar just to show you how important i
think it is and it's important to know
that
a dalton is the mass of a hydrogen atom
it was first described by sir john
dalton in 1784
when he was a professor at cambridge
university
so nowadays nist likes to call it dalton
1 12th of the mass of a carbon atom
they want to relate everything to carbon
so when the aliens come we can talk
about carbon and dalton is 1 12 the mass
of a carbon atom so a hydrogen atom
is the smallest indivisible atomic unit
that you can have
just to keep things in perspective then
the antibody is the molecular weight of
around 147
000 bones 147 kb
the average mass of amino acid is around
120.
so we can look at this and say okay igg
has about
1200 amino acids and it's important to
understand this also
in the context of an exosome evs are
going to be anywhere from
60 to 120 nanometers in size
much larger than the antibond so an
antibody cannot cross the 20 kb
molecular cutoff
and neither can an extracellular vessel
so this is a cute little video or a
positive pressure displacement pump it's
a frictionless pumping system
also tower flow facilitates exchange and
nutrients and waste products
across the fiber cells are growing on
the outside of the fiber
nutrients the waste products can cross
the fiber the
product of interest cannot cross the
fiber we can simply harvest it by using
some syringes and pulling out your
product
on a daily basis
[Music]
so in the laboratory the system designed
to be very simple
temperature is controlled by the
incubator gas composition is controlled
by the incubator
it fits inside any standard incubator
we have a thin cord that goes through
the door for power it's not necessary to
run
anything through the back of the
incubator so we can maintain and
retain our co2 concentration in the
incubator
we work with the cartridge it's very
important to have good sterile technique
we must remember that pasteur was
correct life does not spontaneously
generate
all we're going to do on a daily basis
move it into the hood somewhere in a
laminar flow hood
in a nice aseptic environment
maintenance is only going to take 15
minutes a day we want to measure the
glucose
the rate of glucose uptake i.e the
glucose uptake rate or gur
is going to be an indication of how many
cells we have in the cartridge
how happy the cells are and what's going
on so
as long as the glucose uptake rate is
either plateauing or increasing
uh the cells are very happy we
know from experience that a glucose
uptake rate of
approximately one gram per day means
that we have
about one times 10 to the night cells
total
in the cartridge we're going to
harvest our product harvest volumes be
anywhere from
two milliliters on up to 60 milliliters
concentration of our secreted products
will be anywhere from 10
to 100 times higher than what you'll
have in a regular
bioreactor flask culture
so the advantages of hollow fiber cell
culture are as follows we have a
concentrated product
product is concentrated by the molecular
cut off of the fiber
remains in the extra capillary space
along with cells
where it becomes very highly
concentrated and we can just harvest it
out every day
we see uniform and complete
post-translational modifications
this is because the cells are creating
their own microenvironment
and they're spending much more time in
their optimum homeostatic
physiologic cell culture conditions for
optimum protein production
and cell physiology
we see low apoptosis the cells die
they're necrotic
but they don't split open so it's not
unusual to see
large numbers of dead cells intact dead
cells
in your harvested product but we see
significantly less contamination with
intracellular dna
wholesale proteins and most importantly
membrane fragments
we've developed our protein-free media
cdmhd
chemically defined media for high
density culture
the cell culture environment found in a
homo fiber bioreactor
is fundamentally different from any
other way of growing cells
this makes it possible for us to
specifically simplify
and optimize the media that we use in
conjunction with these bioreactors
so cdmhd is chemically defined
protein free animal component free and
cgmp compliant
one of the things that's important to me
about cdmhd is that it's
not just a product it is a direct
manifestation of the different cell
culture conditions found
in a 3d hollow fiber bioreactor because
cdmac does not work in flask culture cd
means
cdmhd does not work in standard cell
culture systems the cells must be
at a higher density they need to be
generating their own
micro environment so the cells need to
be at least five times ten to seven
cells per mil
or higher in order for cdhd to be able
to support their growth
so we can see over long-term culture
consistency of production in terms of
post-translational modifications
protein purification and ev production
over time
so of course we all know what exosomes
are just a brief review
they're small particles derived in
biological fluids they're anywhere from
30 to 120
nanometers in size they have micro rna
that
may contain their therapeutic activity
inside
vesicles they have proteins on the
exterior they're targeting proteins in
my mind
my own personal theory and hypothesis is
that
evs exist to protect the micro rna
inside the vesicle because you don't
want to have free rna floating around
inside your biological fluids
and we need to be able to direct them to
specific areas for them to exert their
activity so evs
are targeted cell regeneration
um vectors that can be used for many
different therapeutic purposes
so this is a reminder of the standard
methods for producing evs at least up
until
now we're going to utilize 2d plastic
flasks we've already discussed how
non-physiologic that is
and we'll take out the serum so get the
cells to confluence
in the serum containing media we remove
the serum
serum contains a significant amount of
uh
endogenous suction or vesicles we want
to get rid of those and not have them
interfere
so we'll put them into protein-free
media serum free media for about
48 hours and then collect the evs under
these conditions so you can imagine
just how non-physiologic even in the
absence of serum that these kinds of
conditions for
ev production are just a little
experiment that we did
in house we found that if we use cdhd
under these conditions
then we can significantly enhance ev
production for themselves in this
protocol however
it's still not very efficient and keep
in mind that
10 to the night cells generates a lot of
plastic trash
and in this case this is just an example
of what it takes to expand a t75 flask
up to 10 to 9 cells which is going to be
about 50 t225 flask
so it generates a lot of garbage so
there must be a better way of doing
things
so the advantages of how fiber
bioreactors for ev production
are that large numbers of cells can be
cultured in a small space
our standard cartridges c2011 can
support
10 to the ninth cells our larger
cartridge which we're going to be
scaling up to in the next few weeks in
our own lab
the c2018 can support one to three
to one to three to five times ten to the
tenth cells it's quite a range right now
but somewhere between one and five times
ten to the 10th total cells
and a volume of 60 mls the secreted
exosomes will be significantly
concentrated
we're also finding that harvest
frequency has a significant impact on
the efficiency of
collections so we're looking to optimize
that and i'll give a little more data on
that in a minute
so we know we can do continuous
production many cell types over many
months
um so we can set up a continuous
production scheme with a
3d holofiber my reactor
we have protocols where we've used serum
to support the cells
we can put serum into the circulating
media through the ics or intracapillary
space
but the factors in serum that support
cell growth
can cross the fibers the extracellular
vesicles the endogenous extracellular
vesicles that we don't want
cannot cross the fiber so we can safely
use
serum in the uh to support the cells if
we need to
however we found that most cell types
as long as we can get the density up to
uh 10 and 8 cells per mil
we can utilize c cdm hd which of course
is going to be ev-free and it is fully
cgmp compliant
uh mscs mesa counter stem cells we work
with a lot
i'm not going to go into a whole other
another seminar to talk about mscs but
briefly found that uh mesocontal stem
cells regardless of their source
don't seem to proliferate too much
unless they're under special conditions
um i believe that this is just a
function of
mscs and how they behave in nego but
part of the definition of mses these are
common stem cells is that they
attach to plastic and proliferate in a
3d environment they do not appear
to proliferate this is both good news
and bad news
bad news is we need a lot of cells to
see the cartridge
good news is that the cells aren't
proliferating they're not
differentiating
so i'll show that we've been able to
maintain mscs for 45 to 60 days
continuous culture harvesting exosomes
all along
just some of our initial work showed
that with the human adipose derived
mesochinal stem cells
there are one c2011 bioreactor
harvesting once a week we are generating
about
we'll just say nine times ten to the
eleventh we'll fudge it up to ten of the
twelve evs
uh when it's equal in terms of our
control 540
t225 flats ev production
is going to vary a lot in terms of our
comparisons depending on the cell time
depending on the harvesting frequency
and many other factors but this was a
direct comparison that we did one of our
early ones
and in terms of bioactivity we can
demonstrate that
we did see enhanced wound healing
activity produced by these
exosomes uh in this this rat wound
healing model
but more interestingly as collaborators
of ours we worked with
this was a way to make uh exercise or
vesicles inexpensive enough
that they could be used in a commercial
product so in point of fact we have this
product produced
called um
exophase there's an exosome based facial
moisturizer and they've got some some
data on this 95 reduction wrinkles
skin luminescence some
19 18 acceleration cell renewal
um so we've got lots of nice data from
this commercial product that utilizes
our system to produce uh commercially
viable uh extracellular vesicles in this
case they're called
smarticles
this is just another example from one of
our researchers
that's been working from from working
with us from switzerland
and basically what it's showing for a
small cartridge this is our c2025d
uh 450 square centimeters of surface
area
that we get cumulative linear growth of
the evs
and linear production of evs over time
this is bone marrow msc um from human
umbilical cord msc
in this particular case i think we found
perhaps so this is
uh data that i have that has been
published
but there's still some some uh um
data that i still need to get from them
but in this case we can see that
uh they seated two times ten to the
eighth mscs
and they utilize the cell growth factor
the scenes have gotten themselves
proliferate
in any event they seated ten times two
times ten to the eight cells
um and we consumed uh 200 bigs of
glucose per day we expect
and we see that they uh they over time
they did expand
and we were able to culture these mscs
for 44 days
before things started to drop off but
this is going to be important in a
minute
basically they compared 2d uh
msc extracellular vesicles in terms of
cell surface
markers with the 3d uh evs and the cell
surface markers and here we're just
showing
consistency between day 23 and day 55 of
culture
which to me is important because evs
remained uniform and consistent over
time even though the cell population
started to diminish
so i think that this is showing that the
physiology of the cells
was still optimum for ev production
here we've just got a comparison in
terms of particle size
and western blot analysis of the 2d
versus 3d evs in this case we can see
that the 3d ev is equal to about 225
t225 flash
now our poster from uh international
society of extracellular vesicles
we did in conjunction with laura perrin
she had some
human amniotic uh fluid stem cells
that we cultured in our little cartridge
and produce evs for her
and most surprisingly um we found that
regardless of the harvesting interval
whether it was one hour
two hours or every 24 hours eevee
concentration was pretty much the same
uh in the level of around uh two
times ten to the eighth four times ten
minutes uh two point eight times ten to
the tenth
four times ten to the tenth the hourly
harvest um
or if we can harvest it over a day
concentration is the same
so there's a significant either
inhibition
of ev secretion based on external ev
concentration
or um inhibition of secretion
based on this concentration so it's
either inhibition to reuptake
or inhibition secretion based on the
high concentration of evs
in the extra capillary space
here's some of our primary data just
showing
the same particle size distribution um
the cv numbers tetraspan and analysis
showed the weaker expression of some of
the other cv
markers we're not exactly sure what's
the reason for that because the
bioactivity was actually
enhanced in terms of both
fibonacci and co-precipitation and in
vivo injection to alport mice
showing amelioration of protein area
based upon the eevee therapy of the
kidneys
so the advantages here we've got
demonstrated enhanced bioactivity in
many different publications
um we mimic the mammalian secretary
system
long-term uh homeostasis and cell
culture environment
um now the the most important thing
to me is going to be that um many grant
applications are being
criticized because there's just not the
capability and capacity
to produce the number of evs required
for clinical trials or in vivo animal
studies
my my feeling is that hollow fiber
does actually produce the numbers of evs
required
for clinical translation and we have a
project ongoing in our lab that we're
just starting up where we're going to
try to demonstrate
the production of 10 to the 15th we're
gram quantities
of evs and if we look at other
comparative methods that i pulled out of
some journal articles
and some presentations rooster bio is
promoting a micro carrier method for
producing large numbers
of evs 10 to the 13th uvs
so that would actually require
to get the 10 to the 15s would take 100
runs
of this bioreactor to produce 10 of the
15 you know evs
quantum has published some data showing
that they get 10 to the 13th
in 1500 mills of supernatant
and we need to again run 100 uh runs of
their system in order to get to 10 to
the 15th
my expectation is that we'll set up
a cartridge and be able to generate 10
to the 14th
evs in our product uh for under
in a month for under 30 000 cost
now what would a system like this look
like just to look into the future maybe
a little bit this is a diagram of a
closed automated cgmp compliant
model fiber bioreactor system that could
be used to produce
10 of the 14 to 10 of the 15 evs or more
so we can see that the holofiber my
reactor is
the most evolved way the most viva-like
way
of culturing cells and i see great
applications for this
both in terms of producing evs under
physiologic conditions and producing
eb's
in quantity sufficient for clinical
translation
so again i'm john cadwell with fibre
cell systems thanks so very much for
your time